[Music
] Well then, let's begin the promotion examination
.
It
's fine, it's smooth, and it's perfect for me Baan
Why are you all getting the same request,
but you're the only one who's doing well lately Ah, ah, that's
actually a lot of money I've been sending from my parents' house lately  I got it and
lied, I'm sorry for the mistakes in the words I'm talking about to everyone who updated
[Music
] Miracle of the cold weather
Kacha Peeping demon and thought that equipment It seems that it was newly made from the plagiarism of the ruins the other
day Did you do it?  I found a treasure chest and sold
it.
and adventure work in this city
.
People don't qualify as adventurers I'm
fine with announcing that I left a wide-angle car because I cheated on my rewards
, but I don't care if I
stay, but it's no use thinking about something bad, Taro.
I'm a witness, nothing more, nothing less
Head, isn't it a certain slope
?  tero I
refuse